Oscar season is upon us and you might be
pleasantly surprised to hear that Mad
Max fury road and the revenant are
leading the Oscar races the revenant and
Mad Max have collected the most
nominations for the 2016 Academy Awards
the revenant a brutal survival film
starring Leonardo DiCaprio and Tom Hardy
has racked up 12 while Mad Max fury road
another tom party film has earned 10
both films were nominated for Best
Picture while DiCaprio has received his
fourth nod for Best Actor one day leo
one day that Oscar will be yours fury
road was predominantly recognized for
its technical prowess like
cinematography editing and visual
effects meanwhile the Martian was
nominated for Best Picture and Matt
Damon has also joined the list of best
actors for his performance but if that
isn't your kind of sci-fi film then
you'll be happy to know that star wars
the force awakens has also made out
pretty well with five nominations
nominees for Best Picture include the
big short bridge of spies Brooklyn Mad
Max fury road the Martian the revenant
the roof and spotlight Best Actor
nominees include Bryan Cranston for
Trumbo Matt Damon for the Martian
Leonardo DiCaprio for the revenant
Michael Fassbender for Steve Jobs and
Eddie Redmayne for the Danish girl the
nominated best actresses are Cate
Blanchett for Carol brie Larson for room
Jennifer Lawrence for joy and Saoirse
Ronan for Brooklyn for a complete list
of the nominations head over to our
article on gamespot